ah makes me feel weird my favorite
Disney Princess without a doubt was
jasmine Miss Milan obsessed with jasmine
I loved Ariel and I used to swim around
in circles in my bathtub no wow really
she looks like this I guess I never
really thought about it before cuz
Disney Princesses just like are like
that that's just what they are it's just
how they look so unrealistic like she
got all her ribs removed
I think her waist is the same size as
her neck in this photo so basically this
would be my waist but in in the
Photoshop version she looks gorgeous if
all the Disney Princesses had these
weights then it wouldn't seem like any
big deal it's just that you're always
comparing it to this I feel like I've
been conditioned to find be attractive I
get why you do it cuz it's a cartoon or
today toddlers when they watch this
movie are gonna look at this and then
one day look at their waist and be like
why is it the size of my neck a slippery
slope yeah I think I think I wanted to
grow up to look like that but I was
always pretty realistic and didn't think
it would actually happen I know that
it's pretty ridiculous to blame Disney
for people's body image issues but when
you think about it it isn't that crazy
so normal to me that like it didn't feel
weird that goes to show like how like
gross it is is that it's so subliminal I
thought to myself like okay maybe I'm
not as hot as jasmine is but one day I
will be in like when that didn't happen
like that was kind of like damn I loved
Jasmine's little tiny waist so much that
I asked my mother if I could remove a
rib so that my waist Chloe could look
like that I remember the day I was in a
nutrition class in college and realized
that women were supposed to have
stomachs like biologically fat it's
supposed to collect there more than men
and I'm so relieved like maybe Elsa has
a ball in like tiny little waist and her
sister is a little more of like a ruler
shape but hey she's hot too
can't you like mix it up a little bit if
we saw more princesses that more
accurately represent who we are as a
country then like I think that that
would be a good place to start if I
could create a Disney princess but what
I have her look like she would be like
ethnically ambiguous a princess with an
afro he's super athletic and kick a
guy's ass and save the day or maybe one
that has some roles when she bends over
there were some hips I would try to make
like six I didn't like a troop and
they'd all have different types of bods
love to make a Disney Princess who's
more central to the action no one's
gonna save you except for you can be
everything you want to be no matter what
size you are
[Music]